The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
I'm Srini Devadas.
I'm a professor of electrical
engineering and computer
science.
I'm going to be co-lecturing
6.006-- Introduction
to Algorithms-- this term
with professor Erik Domane.
Eric, say hi.
ERIK DOMANE: Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And we
hope you're going
to have a fun time
in 6.006 learning
a variety of algorithms.
What I want to do today is
spend literally a minute or so
on administrative
details, maybe even less.
What I'd like to
do is to tell you
to go to the website that's
listed up there and read it.
And you'll get all
information you
need about what this class
is about from a standpoint
of syllabus; what's expected
of you; the problem set
schedule; the quiz schedule;
and so on and so forth.
I want to dive right in and tell
you about interesting things,
like algorithms and
complexity of algorithms.
I want to spend
some time giving you
an overview of the
course content.
And then we're
going to dive right
in and look at a
particular problem of peak
finding-- both the one
dimensional version and a two
dimensional version-- and
talk about algorithms to solve
this peak finding problem--
both varieties of it.
And you'll find
that there's really
a difference between
these various algorithms
that we'll look at in
terms of their complexity.
And what I mean
by that is you're
going to have different run
times of these algorithms
depending on input
size, based on how
efficient these algorithms are.
And a prerequisite for
this class is 6.042.
And in 6.042 you learned
about asymptotic complexity.
And you'll see that
in this lecture
we'll analyze relatively
simple algorithms today
in terms of their
asymptotic complexity.
And you'll be able
to compare and say
that this algorithm is fasten
this other one-- assuming
that you have large
inputs-- because it's
asymptotically less complex.
So let's dive right in
and talk about the class.
So the one sentence
summary of this class
is that this is about
efficient procedures
for solving problems
on large inputs.
And when I say large
inputs, I mean things
like the US highway
system, a map
of all of the highways
in the United States;
the human genome, which
has a billion letters
in its alphabet; a social
network responding to Facebook,
that I guess has 500
million nodes or so.
So these are large inputs.
Now our definition of large has
really changed with the times.
And so really the 21st
century definition of large
is, I guess, a trillion.
Right?
Back when I was your age
large was like 1,000.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess I'm dating myself here.
Back when Eric was your
age, it was a million.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
But what's happening really
the world is moving faster,
things are getting bigger.
We have the capability of
computing on large inputs,
but that doesn't
mean that efficiency
isn't of paramount concern.
The fact of matter is
that you can, maybe,
scan a billion elements
in a matter of seconds.
But if you had an algorithm
that required cubic complexity,
suddenly you're not talking
about 10 raised to 9,
you're talking about
10 raised to 27.
And even current
computers can't really
handle those kinds of numbers,
so efficiency is a concern.
And as inputs get larger, it
becomes more of a concern.
All right?
So we're concerned about--
--efficient procedures-- for
solving large scale problems
in this class.
And we're concerned
about scalability,
because-- just as,
you know, 1,000
was a big number a
couple of decades ago,
and now it's kind of
a small number-- it's
quite possible that by the
time you guys are professors
teaching this class
in some university
that a trillion is going
to be a small number.
And we're going to be talking
about-- I don't know--
10 raised to 18
as being something
that we're concerned with from
a standpoint of a common case
input for an algorithm.
So scalability is important.
And we want to be able to track
how our algorithms are going
to do as inputs get
larger and larger.
You going to learn a bunch
of different data structures.
We'll call them classic
data structures,
like binary search
trees, hash tables-- that
are called dictionaries
in Python-- and data
structures-- such as balanced
binary search trees-- that
are more efficient than just
the regular binary search trees.
And these are all
data structures
that were invented
many decades ago.
But they've stood
the test of time,
and they continue to be useful.
We're going to augment these
data structures in various ways
to make them more efficient
for certain kinds of problems.
And while you're not going to be
doing a whole lot of algorithm
design in this
class, you will be
doing some design and a
whole lot of analysis.
The class following this
one, 6.046 Designing Analysis
of Algorithms, is
a class that you
should take if
you like this one.
And you can do a whole lot more
design of algorithms in 6.046.
But you will look at
classic data structures
and classical algorithms
for these data structures,
including things like sorting
and matching, and so on.
And one of the nice
things about this class
is that you'll be doing real
implementations of these data
structures and
algorithms in Python.
And in particular are
each of the problem
sets in this class are
going to have both a theory
part to them, and a
programming part to them.
So hopefully it'll
all tie together.
The kinds of things we're going
to be talking about in lectures
and recitations are going
to be directly connected
to the theory parts
of the problem sets.
And you'll be programming the
algorithms that we talk about
in lecture, or augmenting
them, running them.
Figuring out whether they work
well on large inputs or not.
So let me talk a little
bit about the modules
in this class and
the problem sets.
And we hope that
these problem sets
are going to be fun for you.
And by fun I don't mean easy.
I mean challenging and
worthwhile, so at the end of it
you feel like you've
learned something,
and you had some
fun along the way.
All right?
So content wise--
--we have eight
modules in the class.
Each of which,
roughly speaking, has
a problem set
associated with it.
The first of these is what
we call algorithmic thinking.
And we'll kick start
that one today.
We'll look at a particular
problem, as I mentioned,
of peak finding.
And as part of
this, you're going
to have a problem set that's
going to go out today as well.
And you'll find that
in this problem set
some of these algorithms
I talk about today will
be coded in Python and given to.
A couple of them are going
to have bugs in them.
You'll have to analyze the
complexity of these algorithms;
figure out which ones are
correct and efficient;
and write a proof
for one of them.
All right?
So that's sort of an
example problem set.
And you can expect that
most of the problem sets
are going to follow
that sort of template.
All right.
So you'll get a
better sense of this
by the end of the
day today for sure.
Or a concrete sense
of this, because we'll
be done with lecture and you'll
see your first problem set.
We're going to be doing a
module on sorting and trees.
Sorting you now about,
sorting a bunch of numbers.
Imagine if you had
a trillion numbers
and you wanted to sort them.
What kind of algorithm
could use for that?
Trees are a wonderful
data structure.
There's different varieties, the
most common being binary trees.
And there's ways of doing
all sorts of things,
like scheduling, and sorting,
using various kinds of trees,
including binary trees.
And we have a problem set on
simulating a logic network
using a particular kind of
sorting algorithm in a data
structure.
That is going to be
your second problem set.
And more quickly, we're going
to have modules on hashing,
where we do things
like genome comparison.
In past terms we compared a
human genome to a rat genome,
and discovered they
were pretty similar.
99% similar, which
is kind of amazing.
But again, these things
are so large that you
have to have efficiency
in the comparison methods
that you use.
And you'll find that if you
don't get the complexity low
enough, you just won't
be able to complete--
your program won't be able to
finish running within the time
that your problem set is do.
Right?
Which is a bit of a problem.
So that's something to keep
in mind as you test your code.
The fact is that you will get
large inputs to run your code.
And you want to keep
complexity in mind
as you're coding and thinking
about the pseudocode,
if you will, of your
algorithm itself.
We will talk about numerics.
A lot of the time we talk
about such large numbers
that 32 bits isn't enough.
Or 64 bits isn't enough to
represent these numbers.
These numbers have
thousands of bits.
A good example is
RSA encryption,
that is used in
SSL, for example.
And when you go-- use
https on websites,
RSA is used at the back end.
And typically you work
with prime numbers
that are thousands
of bits long in RSA.
So how do you handle that?
How does Python handle that?
How do you write
algorithms that can
deal with what are called
infinite precision numbers?
So we have a module on numerics
in the middle of the term that
talks about that.
Graphs, really a
fundamental data structure
in all of computer science.
You might have heard of the
famous Rubik's cube assignment
from .
006 a 2 by 2 by 2 Rubik's cube.
What's the minimum
number of moves
necessary to go from a
given starting configuration
to the final end configuration,
where all of the faces-- each
of the faces has uniform color?
And that can be posed
as a graph problem.
We'll probably do
that one this term.
In previous terms
we've done other things
like the 15 puzzle.
And so some of
these are tentative.
We definitely know what the
first problem set is like,
but the rest of them are,
at this moment, tentative.
And to finish up shortest paths.
Again in terms past
we've asked you
to write code using a
particular algorithm that
finds the shortest path
from Caltech to MIT.
This time we may do things
a little bit differently.
We were thinking maybe we'll
give you a street map of Boston
and go figure out
if Paul Revere used
the shortest path to get
to where he was going,
or things like that.
We'll try and make it fun.
Dynamic programming is an
important algorithm design
technique that's used
in many, many problems.
And it can be used to do a
variety of things, including
image compression.
How do you compress an image
so the number of pixels
reduces, but it still
looks like the image
that you started out with,
that had many more pixels?
All right?
So you could use dynamic
programming for that.
And finally, advanced topics,
complexity theory, research
and algorithms.
Hopefully by now-- by
this time in the course,
you have been sold
on algorithms.
And most, if not
all of you, would
want to pursue a
carrier in algorithms.
And we'll give you a sense
of what else is there.
We're just scratching the
surface in this class,
and there's many, many
classes that you can possibly
take if you want to continue
in-- to learn about algorithms,
or to pursue a
career in algorithms.
All right?
So that's the
story of the class,
or the synopsis of the class.
And I encourage you to go spend
a few minutes on the website.
In particular please read the
collaboration policy, and get
a sense of what is
expected of you.
What the rules are in terms
of doing the problem sets.
And the course
grading break down,
the grading policies are all
listed on the website as well.
All right.
OK.
So let's get started.
I want to talk about
a specific problem.
And talk about algorithms
for a specific problem.
We picked this problem, because
it's so easy to understand.
And they're fairly
straightforward algorithms
that are not particularly
efficient to solve
this problem.
And so this is a, kind
of, a toy problem.
But like a lot of
toy problems, it's
very evocative in that it
points out the issues involved
in designing
efficient algorithms.
So we'll start with
a one dimensional
version of what we
call peak finding.
And a peak finder is something
in the one dimensional case.
Runs on an array of numbers.
And I'm just putting--
--symbols for each of
these numbers here.
And the numbers are
positive, negative.
We'll just assume
they're all positive,
it doesn't really matter.
The algorithms we
describe will work.
And so we have this
one dimensional array
that has nine
different positions.
And a through i are numbers.
And we want to find a peak.
And so we have to define
what we mean by a peak.
And so, in particular,
as an example,
position 2 is a
peak if, and only
if, b greater than or equal to
a, and b greater than or equal
to c.
So it's really a very local
property corresponding
to a peak.
In the one dimensional
case, it's trivial.
Look to your left.
Look to your right.
If you are equal or greater
than both of the elements
that you see on the left and
the right, you're a peak.
OK?
And in the case of
the edges, you only
have to look to one side.
So position 9 is a peak if i
greater than or equal to h.
So you just have to
look to your left there,
because you're all the way
on the right hand side.
All right?
So that's it.
And the statement of the
problem, the one dimensional
version, is find the
peak if it exists.
All right?
That's all there is to it.
I'm going to give you a
straightforward algorithm.
And then we'll see
if we can improve it.
All right?
You can imagine that the
straightforward algorithm is
something that just, you
know, walks across the array.
But we need that as a starting
point for building something
more sophisticated.
So let's say we start
from left and all
we have is one
traversal, really.
So let's say we have
1, 2, and then we
have n over 2 over
here corresponding
to the middle of
this n element array.
And then we have
n minus 1, and n.
What I'm interested
in doing is, not only
coming up with a
straightforward algorithm,
but also precisely
characterizing
what its complexity
is in relation
to n, which is the
number of inputs.
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Why do
you say if it exists
when the criteria
in the [INAUDIBLE]
guarantees [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
I was going to get to that.
So if you look at the
definition of the peak,
then what I have here is
greater than or equal to.
OK?
And so this-- That's a great
question that was asked.
Why is there "if it
exists" in this problem?
Now in the case where I have
greater than or equal to,
then-- this is a homework
question for you,
and for the rest of you-- argue
that any array will always
have a peak.
OK?
Now if you didn't have the
greater than or equal to,
and you had a greater than,
then can you make that argument?
No, you can't.
Right?
So great question.
In this case it's
just a question--
You would want to
modify this problem
statement to find the peak.
But if I had a different
definition of a peak-- and this
is part of algorithmic thinking.
You want to be able to create
algorithms that are general,
so if the problem
definition changes on you,
you still have a starting
point to go attack
the second version
of the problem.
OK?
So you could eliminate
this in the case
of the greater than or
equal to definition.
The "if it exists", because
a peak will always exist.
But you probably want
to argue that when
you want to show the
correctness of your algorithm.
And if in fact you had
a different definition,
well you would have to create
an algorithm that tells you
for sure that a peak
doesn't exist, or find
a peak if it exists.
All right?
So that's really
the general case.
Many a time it's possible that
you're asked to do something,
and you can't actually give
an answer to the question,
or find something that satisfies
all the constraints required.
And in that case, you want to
be able to put up your hand
and say, you know what?
I searched long and hard.
I searched exhaustively.
Here's my argument that
I searched exhaustively,
and I couldn't find it.
Right?
If you do that, you
get to keep your job.
Right?
Otherwise there's
always the case
that you didn't
search hard enough.
So it's nice to
have that argument.
All right?
Great.
Thanks for the question.
Feel free to interrupt.
Raise your hand, and
I'm watching you guys,
and I'm happy to answer
questions at any time.
So let's talk about the
straightforward algorithm.
The straightforward
algorithm is something
that starts from the left
and just walks across.
And you might have something
that looks like that.
All right?
By that-- By this I mean
the numbers are increasing
as you start from the
left, the peak is somewhere
in the middle, and then
things start decreasing.
Right?
So in this case, you know,
this might be the peak.
You also may have
a situation where
the peak is all the
way on the right,
you started from the left.
And it's 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, literally
in terms of the numbers.
And you're going to look at
n elements going all the way
to the right in order
to find the peak.
So in the case of
the middle you'd
look at n over 2 elements.
If it was right in the middle.
And the complexity,
worst case complexity--
--is what we call theta n.
And it's theta n, because
in the worst case,
you may have to look
at all n elements.
And that would be the case
where you started from the left
and you had to go all
the way to the right.
Now remember theta n is
essentially something
that's says of the order of n.
So it gives you both the lower
bound and an upper bound.
Big [? O ?] of n is
just upper bound.
And what we're
saying here is, we're
saying this algorithm
that starts from the left
is going to, essentially,
require in the worst case
something that's a
constant times n.
OK?
And you know that
constant could be 1.
You could certainly
set things up that way.
Or if you had a different
kind of algorithm,
maybe you could work
on the constant.
But bottom line, we're only
concerned, at this moment,
about as asymptotic complexity.
And the asymptotic complexity
of this algorithm is linear.
All right?
That make sense?
OK.
So someone help me do better.
How can we do better?
How can we lower the
asymptotic complexity
of a one dimensional
peak finder?
Anybody want to
take a stab at that?
Yeah?
Back there.
AUDIENCE: Do a
binary search subset.
You look at the
middle, and whatever
is higher-- whichever side is
higher, then cut that in half,
because you know there's a peak.
PROFESSOR: On--
AUDIENCE: For example
if you're in the middle
on the right side--
there's a higher number
then you would just
look at that, because you know
that your peak's somewhere
in there.
And you continue
cutting in half.
PROFESSOR: Excellent!
Excellent!
That's exactly right.
So you can-- You can do
something different, which
is essentially try and
break up this problem.
Use a divide and conquer
strategy, and recursively break
up this one dimensional
array into smaller arrays.
And try and get this
complexity down.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are we assuming
that there's only one peak?
PROFESSOR: No, we're not.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: It's find
a peak if it exists.
And in this case
it's, "find a peak",
because of the definition.
We don't really need
this as it was discussed.
All right?
OK.
So--
So that was a great answer,
and-- You know this class
after while is
going to get boring.
Right?
Every class gets boring.
So we, you know, try and
break the monotony here a bit.
And so-- And then the other
thing that we realized
was that these seats
you're sitting on-- this
is a nice classroom-- but
the seats you're sitting on
are kind of hard.
Right?
So what Eric and I
did was we decided
we'll help you guys
out, especially the ones
who are-- who are
interacting with us.
And we have these--
[LAUGHTER]
--cushions that
are 6.006 cushions.
And, you know, that's a 2
by 2 by 2 Rubik's cube here.
And since you answered the first
question, you get a cushion.
This is kind of like a
Frisbee, but not really.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not sure-- I'm not sure
I'm going to get it to you.
But the other
thing I want to say
is this is not a baseball game.
Right?
Where you just grab the
ball as it comes by.
This is meant for him, my
friend in the red shirt.
So here you go.
Ah, too bad.
All right.
It is soft.
So, you know, it won't-- it
won't hurt you if hits you.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So we got a bunch of these.
And raise your hands,
you know, going
to ask-- There's going
to be-- I think-- There's
some trivial questions that
we're going to ask just
to make sure you're awake.
So an answer to that
doesn't get you a cushion.
But an answer like--
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Chase.
PROFESSOR: Chase.
An answer like
Chase just gave is--
that's a good answer to
a nontrivial question.
That gets you a cushion.
OK?
All right, great.
So let's put up by
Chase's algorithm up here.
I'm going to write it
out for the 1D version.
So what we have here is
a recursive algorithm.
So the picture you want
to keep in your head
is this picture
that I put up there.
And this is a divide
and conquer algorithm.
You're going to see this over
and over-- this paradigm--
over and over in 6.006.
We're going to look at
the n over 2 position.
And we're going to
look to the left,
and we're going to
look to the right.
And we're going to
do that in sequence.
So--
--if a n over 2 is less than
a n over 2 minus 1, then--
--only look at the left half.
1 through n over 2 minus 1 to
look for peak-- for a peak.
All right?
So that's step one.
And you know I could
put it on the right hand
side or the left hand side,
doesn't really matter.
I chose to do the left hand
side first, the left half.
And so what I've done is,
through that one step,
if in fact you have that
condition-- a n over 2
is less than a n over 2 minus
1-- then you move to your left
and you work on one
half of the problem.
But if that's not the case,
then if n over-- n over 2
is less than a over n
over-- n by 2 plus 1,
then only look at n over 2
plus 1 through n for a peak.
So I haven't bothered
writing out all the words.
They're exactly the same
as the left hand side.
You just look to
the right hand side.
Otherwise if both of these
conditions don't fire,
you're actually done.
OK?
That's actually the best case
in terms of finishing early,
at least in this recursive step.
Because now the n over
2 position is a peak.
Because what you found is
that the n over 2 position
is greater than or equal to
both of its adjacent positions,
and that's exactly the
definition of a peak.
So you're done.
OK?
So all of this is good.
You want to write an argument
that this algorithm is correct.
And I'm not going
to bother with that.
I just wave my hands a
bit, and you all nodded,
so we're done with that.
But the point being you
will see in your problem set
a precise argument for a more
complicated algorithm, the 2D
version of this.
And that should be a template
for you to go write a proof,
or an argument, a
formal argument,
that a particular
algorithm is correct.
That it does what
it claims to do.
And in this case it's two,
three lines of careful reasoning
that essentially say, given
the definition of the peak,
that this is going to
find a peak in the array
that you're given.
All right?
So we all believe that
this algorithm is correct.
Let's talk now about the
complexity of this algorithm.
Because the whole
point of this algorithm
was because we didn't
like this theta
n complexity corresponding to
the straightforward algorithm.
So it'd like to do better.
So what I'd like to
do is ask one of you
to give me a recurrence relation
of the kind, you know, T of n
equals blah, blah, blah.
That would correspond to
this recursive algorithm,
this divide and
conquer algorithm.
And then using that, I'd like
to get to the actual complexity
in terms of what the theta
of complexity corresponds to.
Yeah?
Back there?
AUDIENCE: So the worst
case scenario if T of n
is going to be some
constant amount of time--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --it takes to
investigate whether a certain
element is [INAUDIBLE], plus--
[COUGH]
--T of n over 2?
PROFESSOR: Great.
Exactly right.
That's exactly right.
So if you look at this
algorithm and you say,
from a computation
standpoint, can I
write an equation
corresponding to the execution
of this algorithm?
And you say, T of n is the work
that this algorithm does on--
as input of size n.
OK?
Then I can write this equation.
And this theta 1 corresponds
to the two comparisons
that you do looking at--
potentially the two comparisons
that you do-- looking
at the left hand
side and the right hand side.
So that's-- 2 is a constant,
so that's why we put theta 1.
All right?
So you get a cushion, too.
Watch out guys.
Whoa!
Oh actually that wasn't so bad.
Good.
Veers left, Eric.
Veers left.
So if you take this and
you start expanding it,
eventually you're going
to get to the base
case, which is T
of 1 is theta 1.
Right?
Because you have a one element
array you just for that array
it's just going to
return that as a peak.
And so if you do that, and
you expand it all the way out,
then you can write T of n
equals theta 1 plus theta 1.
And you're going to do this
log to the base 2 of n times.
And adding these
all up, gives you
a complexity theta log 2 of n.
Right?
So now you compare
this with that.
And there's really
a huge difference.
There's an exponential
difference.
If you coded up this
algorithm in Python--
and I did-- both these
algorithms for the 1D version--
and if you run it on n
being 10 million or so,
then this algorithm
takes 13 seconds.
OK?
The-- The theta 10
algorithm takes 13 seconds.
And this one takes
0.001 seconds.
OK?
Huge difference.
So there is a big difference
between theta n and theta log
n.
It's literally the difference
between 2 raised to n, and n.
It makes sense to try
and reduce complexity
as you can see,
especially if you're
talking about large inputs.
All right?
And you'll see that
more clearly as we
go to a 2D version
of this problem.
All right?
So you can't really
do better for the 1D.
The 1D is a
straightforward problem.
It gets a little
more interesting--
the problems get a
little-- excuse me,
the algorithms get a
little more sophisticated
when we look at a 2D
version of peak finding.
So let's talk about
the 2D version.
So as you can imagine
in the 2D version
you have a matrix, or a
two dimensional array.
And we'll say this thing
has n rows and m columns.
And now we have to
define what a peak is.
And it's a hill.
It's the obvious
definition of a peak.
So if you had a in
here, c, b, d, e.
Then as you can guess, a is
a 2D peak if, and only if,
a greater than or equal to b;
a greater than or equal to d, c
and e.
All right?
So it's a little hill up there.
And again I've used the
greater than or equal to here,
so that's similar to
the 1D in the case
that you'll always find
a peak in any 2D matrix.
Now again I'll give you the
straightforward algorithm,
and we'll call it the
Greedy Ascent algorithm.
And the Greedy Ascent algorithm
essentially picks a direction
and, you know, tries to
follow that direction in order
to find a peak.
So for example, if I
had this particular--
--matrix; 14, 13,
12, 15, 9, 11, 17--
Then what might happen is if
I started at some arbitrary
midpoint-- So the
Greedy Ascent algorithm
has to make choices
as to where to start.
Just like we had
different cases here,
you have to make a choice
as to where to start.
You might want to
start in the middle,
and you might want to
work your way left first.
Or you're going to all--
You just keep going left,
our keep going right.
And if you hit an
edge, you go down.
So you make some choices as
to what the default traversal
directions are.
And so if you say you
want to start with 12,
you are going to go look
for something to left.
And if it's greater than, you're
going to follow that direction.
If it's not, if it's
less, then you're
going to go in the other
direction, in this case,
for example.
So in this case you'll go to
12, 13 , 14, 15, 16, 17, 19,
and 20.
And you'd find-- You
'd find this peak.
Now I haven't given you
the specific details
of a Greedy Ascent algorithm.
But I think if you look at
the worst case possibilities
here, with respect
to a given matrix,
and for any given
starting point,
and for any given strategy-- in
terms of choosing left first,
versus right first, or down
first versus up first--
you will have a
situation where-- just
like we had in the 1D
case-- you may end up
touching a large fraction of
the elements in this 2D array.
OK?
So in this case, we
ended up, you know,
touching a bunch of
different elements.
And it's quite possible that
you could end up touching--
starting from the midpoint--
you could up touching half
the elements, and in some cases,
touching all the elements.
So if you do a worst case
analysis of this algorithm--
a particular algorithm with
particular choices in terms
of the starting point and
the direction of search--
a Greedy Ascent algorithm would
have theta n m complexity.
All right?
And in the case where n
equals m, or m equals n,
you'd have theta n
squared complexity.
OK?
I won't spend very
much time on this,
because I want to talk
to you about the divide
and conquer versions of this
algorithm for the 2D peak.
But hopefully you're
all with me with respect
to what the worst
case complexity is.
All right?
People buy that?
Yeah.
Question back there.
AUDIENCE: Can you-- Is
that an approximation?
Or can you actually get
to n times m traversals?
PROFESSOR: So there are specific
Greedy Ascent algorithms,
and specific matrices
where, if I give you
the code for the algorithm, and
I give you a specific matrix,
that I could make you touch
all of these elements.
That's correct.
So we're talking
about worst case.
You're being very
paranoid when you
talk about worst
case complexity.
And so I'm-- hand
waving a bit here,
simply because I haven't
given you the specifics
of the algorithm yet.
Right?
This is really a
set of algorithms,
because I haven't
given you the code,
I haven't told you
where it starts,
and which direction it goes.
But you go, do
that, fix it, and I
would be the person who tries to
find the worst case complexity.
Suddenly it's very
easy to get to theta n
m in terms of having some
constant multiplying n times m.
But you can definitely
get to that constant
being very close to 1.
OK?
If not 1.
All right.
So let's talk about
divide and conquer.
And let's say that
I did something
like this, where I just tried
to jam the binary search
algorithm into the 2D version.
All right?
So what I'm going to do is--
--I'm going to pick the middle
column, j equals m over 2.
And I'm going to
find a 1D peak using
whatever algorithm I want.
And I'll probably end up using
the more efficient algorithm,
the binary search
version that's gone
all the way to the left
of the board there.
And let's say I find a
binary peak at (i, j).
Because I've picked a column,
and I'm just finding a 1D peak.
So this is j equals m over 2.
That's i.
Now I use (i,j).
In particular row i as a start--
--to find a 1D peak on row i.
And I stand up here,
I'm really happy.
OK?
Because I say, wow.
I picked a middle column,
I found a 1D peak,
that is theta m complexity to
find a 1D peak as we argued.
And one side-- the theta m--
AUDIENCE: Log n.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
You're right.
The log n complexity,
that's what this was.
So I do have that here.
Yeah.
Log n complexity.
Thanks, Eric.
And then once I do that, I
can find a 1D peak on row i.
In this case row
i would be m wide,
so it would be log m complexity.
If n equals m, then I have
a couple of steps of log n,
and I'm done.
All right?
Am I done?
No.
Can someone tell me
why I'm not done?
Precisely?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Because when
you do the second part
to find the peak in
row i, you might not
have that column
peak-- There might not
be a peak on the column anymore.
PROFESSOR: That's
exactly correct.
So this algorithm is incorrect.
OK?
It doesn't work.
It's efficient, but incorrect.
OK?
It's-- You want to be correct.
You know being correcting
and inefficient
is definitely better than
being inefficient-- I'm sorry.
Being incorrect and efficient.
So this is an
efficient algorithm,
in the sense that it will
only take log n time,
but it doesn't work.
And I'll give you
a simple example
here where it doesn't work.
The problem is--
--a 2D peak--
--may not exist--
--on row i.
And here's an example of that.
Actually this is-- This is
exactly the example of that.
Let's say that I
started with this row.
Since it's-- I'm starting
with the middle row,
and I could start with
this one or that one.
Let's say I started
with that one.
I end up finding a peak.
And if this were 10 up here,
I'd choose 12 as a peak.
And it's quite possible
that I return 12 as a peak.
Even though 19 is
bigger, because 12
is a peak given
10 and 11 up here.
And then when I choose
this particular row,
and I find a peak on
this row, it would be 14.
That is a 1D peak on this row.
But 14 is not a 2D peak.
OK?
So this particular example,
14 would return 14.
And 14 is not a 2D peak.
All right?
You can collect your
cushion after the class.
So not so good.
Look like an efficient
algorithm, but doesn't work.
All right?
So how can we get to
something that actually works?
So the last algorithm that
I'm going to show you--
And you'll see four different
algorithms in your problem
set--
--that you'll have to analyze
the complexity for and decide
if they're efficient,
and if they're correct.
But here's a-- a
recursive version
that is better than,
in terms of complexity,
than the Greedy
Ascent algorithm.
And this one works.
So what I'm going to do
is pick a middle column.
j equals m over 2 as before.
I'm going to find the
global maximum on column j.
And that's going
to be at (i, j).
I'm going to compare (i comma
j minus 1), (i comma j),
and (i,j plus 1).
Which means that once I've
found the maximum in this row,
all I'm going to look to
the left and the right,
and compare.
I'm going to pick
the left columns.
If (i comma j minus 1) is
greater than (i comma j)--
and similarly for the right.
And if in fact I-- either
of these two conditions
don't fire, and what
I have is (i comma j)
is greater than or equal
to (i comma j minus 1)
and (i comma j plus
1), then I'm done.
Just like I had
for the 1D version.
If (i comma j) is greater
than or equal to (i comma
j minus 1), and (i comma j
plus 1), that implies (i, j)
is a 2D peak.
OK?
And the reason that
is the case, is
because (i comma j) was the
maximum element in that column.
So you know that
you've compared it
to all of the adjacent elements,
looking up and looking down,
that's the maximum element.
Now you've look at the
left and the right,
and in fact it's greater
than or equal to the elements
on the left and the right.
And so therefore it's a 2D peak.
OK?
So in this case, when you pick
the left or the right columns--
you'll pick one of
them-- you're going
to solve the new problem with
half the number of columns.
All right?
And again, you have to
go through an analysis,
or an argument, to make sure
that this algorithm is correct.
But its intuitively correct,
simply because it matches
the 1D version
much more closely.
And you also have your condition
where you break away right
here, where you have a 2D
peak, just like the 1D version.
And what you've done
is break this matrix up
into half the size.
And that's essentially
why this algorithm works.
When you have a single column--
--find the global
maximum and you're done.
All right?
So that's the base case.
So let me end with
just writing out
what the recurrence relation
for the complexity of this
is, and argue what the overall
complexity of this algorithm
is.
And then I'll give
you the bad news.
All right.
So overall what you have is, you
have something like T of (n, m)
equals T of (n, m
over 2) plus theta n.
Why is that?
Well n is the number of rows,
m is the number of columns.
In one case you'll be
breaking things down
into half the number of
columns, which is m over 2.
And in order to find
the global maximum,
you'll be doing theta
n work, because you're
finding the global maximum.
Right?
You just have to
scan it-- this--
That's the way-- That's
what it's going to take.
And so if you do that, and
you go run it through--
and you know that T of
(n, 1) is theta n-- which
is this last part over
here-- that's your base case.
You get T of (n, m) is theta
of n added to theta of n,
log of m times--
log 2 of m times.
Which is theta of
n-- log 2 of m.
All right?
So you're not done
with peak finding.
What you'll see is at four
algorithms coded in Python--
I'm not going to give away
what those algorithms are,
but you'll have
to recognize them.
You will have seen versions
of those algorithms
already in lecture.
And your job is going to be to
analyze the algorithms, as I
said before, prove that
one of them is correct,
and find counter-examples for
the ones that aren't correct.
The course staff
will stick around
here to answer questions--
logistical questions--
or questions about lecture.
And I owe that
gentleman a cushion.